هل بدا الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد كانت
الترجيحات وتسريبات الاستخباراتيه ان يبدا
ما يعرف بالهجوم المضاد في الربيع على ان
يتركز في شرق اوكرانيا وجنوبها لكنها
بدايات الصيف وتصعيد الاخير لم يكن في
اوكرانيا بل في روسيا نفسها تتهم موسكو
كيف بشن هذه الهجمات لكن كيف تنفي علاقتها
بها وتحيرها الى روس مناهضين للسلطات في
موسكو ليس اخر هذه الهجمات استهداف من
وصفهم جهاز امن الدوله الروسي بالمخربين
الاوكرانيين عمود طاقه كهربائيه فيلينجراد
للطاقه النوويه غرب روسيا اضافه الى
استهداف خطوط للطاقه في محطه كالينين
بمقاطعه تير شمال غرب موسكو يتزامن هذا
الهجوم مع اعلان حاكم مقاطعه بيلوغرود
الروسيه عن اسقاط مسيره اوكرانيه قرب
المدينه التي شهدت قبل ايام قليله هجوما
وصفته وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بالعبر للحدود
نفدته مجموعات عسكريه اوكرانيه اليوميه
باستخدام معدات عسكريه غربيه صنع بينما
قال ما يسمى بفيلق المتطوعين الروس انه
نفذ عمليه ناجحه في المنطقه بل توعد بمزيد
من الضربات ملامح هذا التصعيد في العمق
الروسي ربما بدات تتشكل مع استهداف
الكريملم بطائره مسيره بدايه الشهر الجاري
ووفق ما نقلته نيويورك تايمز اخيرا عن
مسؤولين امريكيين فان ذلك الهجوم كان على
الارجح بتدبير وحدات عسكريه او
استخباراتيه اوكرانيه رغم نفي كيف المتكرر
استهداف الكرملين لم يقف التصعيد على هجوم
الكرملين بل شمل كذلك استهداف مصفاه
اليسكي للنفط بطائره مسيره لمرتين خلال
يومين فقط ناهيك عن الاستهداف المستمر
لشبه جزيره القرم وليس اخيرا استهداف
الاسطول الروسي في البحر الاسود اذ اعلنت
موسكو ان سفينه استطلاع عسكريه روسيه
تعرضت لهجوم نفذته كيف باستخدام زوارق
مسيره
رسميا لا يدعم الغرب اي هجوم على الاراضي
الروسيه وسبق للبيت الابيض ان كرر ذلك
وامتنع عن تصدير اسلحه الى اوكرانيا يصل
مداها الى الاراضي الروسيه وفي اخر تصريح
له اكد البيت الابيض انه لا يؤيد استخدام
المعدات العسكريه الامريكيه لشن هجمات
داخل روسيا رغم ما نقلته نيويورك تايمز
بان القوات المواليه لاوكرانيا استخدمت
مدرعات امريكيه هنا يبرز الحديث عن طائرات
اف 16 الامريكيه التي وافقت واشنطن على
تزويد كييف بها فهل سيكون دورها دفاعيا
فقط ام قد تستخدمها اوكرانيا في تنفيذ
هجمات داخل الاراضي الروسيه لا جواب واضحا
بعد لكن ما يبدو واضحا ان سلسله هجمات
نفذت داخل الاراضي الروسيه اخيرا وهذا ما
يحيل الى تصريحات مستشار الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه الذي قال ان روسيا لا تستوعب
ما يحدث فعمليات المقاومه تتوسع في مناطق
الروسيه وهو يرى ان الهجوم المضاده سلسله
من العمليات يجري تنفيذها بالفعل وليس
خطوه واحده اما موسكو فتقول على لسان وزير
دفاعها ان الرد على اي توغلات جديده عبر
الحدود سيكون قاسيا